nice to meet you as to me I'm such a fan
of the show especially your character
thank you I'm really excited because you
know you have a new love interest yeah
yeah what can you tell us about David
David Schwimmer is my new love interest
yeah and he plays Noah and he goes by
the West Side curmudgeon so he's kind of
a cranky guy he he's a famous blogger
and he has as far away from Ross Geller
as you could possibly get he's a
complicated guy and she's into him mmm
she's really into him what's it been
like working with David amazing yeah and
we've never worked together before oh no
I mean like you know we would cross
paths before but we never actually
worked together and it immediately felt
very comfortable and I think it's
because both of us started in the
theater and so we have sort of a similar
vocabulary and yeah and he's a New
Yorker and I'm a New Yorker and so yeah
it just it just felt good
so will a stepbrother how crazy is that
how great I wasn't expecting it I don't
either
it's like what a now I was like only our
writers I mean our writers are geniuses
they are geniuses how does this affect
your relationship on the show it's too
soon to tell it's awkward mm-hmm
it's awkward I'd like to see what
happens at Thanksgiving that'll be that
would be an interesting episode yeah
people say that you and will you know
your characters you guys are a little
bit toxic unhealthy relationship they
keep saying it from do you feel that way
no no no I don't I don't I don't now I
think their relationship is healthier
now than it was
20 years ago yeah I think that you know
we grace isn't a place where she feels
really good about her life choices
you know she's single and she does she's
not a mother she's got a career that is
you know really successful and she's got
friends who are her chosen family and
you know and Willis is her her bestie
and and he's single as well and we're
and he's changing careers and you know
it just it just works and New York is
expensive I don't think people in the
middle of the country understand how
expensive it is
so Will and Grace you guys talk about a
lot of world issues really you guys
really go in for it is there anything in
particular story line wise that we can
expect this season oh you could expect
us to talk about everything that is
happening in the world today yeah week
by week I mean that's you know what
we've we've always done yeah and you
know just the things that are happening
in the world are just different than
they were 20 years ago so will we talk
about immigration and we talked about
the wall and we you know with all of the
things that are in the papers today we
touch on but in the Will and Grace way
you know it's it's always organic to the
storyline it doesn't we don't lay on it
heavily you know our making people laugh
is our number one priority a lot of
guest stars very new is there anybody on
the wish list for you Barbara Streisand
yeah I want her to play my aunt whom
they want her to play Debbie Reynolds
sister oh we could do like a petition I
feel like don't you think the fans of
Will & Grace could do it come on people
come on don't come on don't you think
that would be an epic but that would be
epic
yes my aunt loved it thank you so thank
you thank you